welcome to Luke why the what what is
this oh my god Oh
[Music]
80 million club merged jacket oh I like
that
hmm that's what I'm talking about eighty
million subscribers goddamn it I bet you
I bet your TV series doesn't have 80
million subscribers well I bet t-series
doesn't have an 80 million subscriber
merch jacket that's right everybody only
if you have 80 million subscribers you
get to wear this or if you buy it
link in the description also this video
sponsored by this changes everything
sixty thousand output god damn the
subreddit is now as 1.1 Jesus Christ
when Felix realized that pure news has
more viewers than books which makes Pew
news a mainstream media I mean I already
knew this this is why they're so goddamn
salty and may I say Peters is the most
respect the new source out there and I
can actually say that because that's my
opinion which I'm allowed to have oh god
it's my parents petition for Felix
parents to whose main review and tell us
embarrassing childhood story well you
can forget about it next name we're
sinking voice oh god this is gonna be a
sad episode isn't it a sad episode of
life oh god it is sad
is that a sad version of visa we're so
guys please it is so sad you know I
pretty much will take the help from
anyone at this point I mean I got the
help from Logan Paul I think it's safe
to say that I'm pretty desperate and I
want to be fully clear I have no other
plans okay I'm all out of trap cards at
this point I got nothing
t-series is around the corner and I got
nothing do something
you already did something well I don't
know that we have to get to a hundred
million so I can sell the hundred
million merge come on what are you doing
putting a pity pie ad in the Super Bowl
that's something pretty good pretty bad
in a Super Bowl so that pure does can
coffee strike the event you know it's a
joke but it's fully it's a great idea
you are YouTube's wise you know today
history has remained a hundred thousand
damn okay that's pretty cool I guess I
have to make another song a million and
it's already at one point one goddamn
this subreddit man I'm so glad I picked
such a great name for it PewDiePie
submissions what a great name so guys
we're dirty we big YouTube gaming that's
right I'm the number one gamer I am
they're the biggest gamer in the whole
world now pretty pie is the supreme
gamer
all hail supreme gamer of PewDiePie
Felix Kjellberg making fan art for Felix
making fan art for bread so you had
better chance at making it - no stop it
bright stop it
this dog can smell people who helped
people
t-series while he's smelling me I sure
as hell ain't sure if it smells on you
okay once t-series takes over and they
send all of us to the gulag don't come
complaining to me going like oh I wish I
wish I said subscribe to pay the pyre
now I am a slave and I have to do all
this stuff I don't like don't do that
don't pull that on me afterwards oh I'm
sorry PewDiePie oh I'm sorry I never
said subscribe to pretty pie
alright it's now or never do your part
I've seen this goddamn level 50 mafia
bus
I like how you draw hair on my leg I
really appreciate that thank you very
nice I cannot confirm if I'm Sookie
she's a Nazi or not but it's a very nice
fan art to say the least
who are your favorite animators on
YouTube hard to say your algorithm
destroyed most of them ooh
what you didn't seal the animators in
YouTube rewind they're all in YouTube
rewind hey look guys there's animators
just a normal day at the sub Beauty pie
is currently oh god the end is near the
end is near oh god damn it
okay guys you guys are talking like it's
already over
it's not over yet and we're far from
over we have a lot of fighting power
left gum buddy mash suit coming in a
little funny show me this show me what a
looper your babies a summons to County
are linear they can slalom bottom is you
know what push empathy someone's bald
Brad and redhead dudes nice and that's a
nice shirt though 2016 have you ever
kissed yourself in the mirror
Jack yes shake my head 2019 well
drinking yourself as GPU that's way
different don't make me laugh ah
PewDiePie it seems accurate because
everyone is saying that me and Marcus
the same height which this is ridiculous
179 that's
ridiculous how tall is PewDiePie I'm 180
and I'm way taller
this makes no sense how tall is
jacksepticeye Yeah right
Yeah right who's making this up how tall
Paul is Brian oh what the hell
Brad well Brad is actually taller than
me and I'm confused creepier yeah it's
got me
definitely screen saver I made prepare
what that's sick that's really good
hey what is this real actually they do
control the training page they let it
run mostly on its own but they will put
things up there that are definitely not
trendy because they want to this isn't
actually correct training uses a bunch
of cygnus to automatically show a list
of videos that highlight what's
happening on YouTube and in the world
there uses a bunch of signals what the
hell
one of those signals must be
automatically filled a video why am i
laughing it's just sad
hey Wow okay so me left PewDiePie right
thank you for a clarifying night I had
no idea I was like whoa which one is it
and his first fanmeet impact Allah 2012
me and my friends came late so we didn't
get a signed poster well you did get an
epic brofist how tall were you back then
what I see everyone's trying to figure
out my height there's no way Felix is
511 there you don't know that pretty pie
breeze this sub right that 10 yeah
should I be concerned what is wrong with
you guys do you not have any more
interesting hobbies yeah okay that's
good I'll save that for later that goes
into my cringe company
for every upload I will make an account
and sub to PewDiePie
okay well 30,000 steps namaste
thank you very much the sub gap is
getting close
yes it's time to reveal my trump card
yes
finally the trump card cuz I'm all out
of those activate my +4 card on
PewDiePie please and 4 million
subscribers don't think that's how it
works
Jack black on meme review with PewDiePie
please make it happen Jack Black I need
you more than ever there it is
it's a big difference there has to be a
big difference I took a picture with Ben
Shapiro
and told him I liked him on me yeah
that's so sweet
it looks so happy oh my god what is with
all the crossovers it's too early for
tears stop trying and stop playing and
start subscribing stop crying start
subscribing stop crying
start subscribing chant with me chunka
chunka chunka joking if he was trolling
with the codes at least like I would
respect that you know if someone
intentionally did a she apology and just
added a bunch of Amazon gift codes as a
meme then yeah I could respect that but
Chinese man killed an Ethan by dog in
Hong Kong this morning the old
switcheroo I am so proud of this
community guys thank you oh yeah me me
after watching Zhu Li ads oh boy oh my
god yeah it's amazing when Pierce height
isn't given in terms of football fields
alright then keep your secret I think
I'm like five or six football field
posing a green screen so Brad can put
whatever mean he wants
okay ninety-four letters it's the
longest word in Swedish
let's make Felix pronounce it I never
heard about this it's more violent
actually belongs Queens but that it back
for the inspection I'll be clear I got
into it with Sir Walter Lantz yes of
course
poor going like say gulags Queens
swarming sexy blogs Queen Smoot screw
that [ __ ] for the expression will be
clan that's magazines for the words for
about that ends damn whoa hello there
looks down shyly who is this pulls out
chest its GG James from history right ok
can you start with the asterisk who's
that mate septic ER okay we're done here
wait I can fix it subscribes to
beautiful I'm listening see there you go
holy damn that is actually sick beautify
the mean killer spent 40 hours on this
my last attempt took 7.5 well I saw it
now
unless Brides cuts it out and he's an
act but if you - no one will know about
there's 15 hidden references damn that's
it me 399 you got a knuckles I didn't
see that that's so cool okay
that's sick thank you very much this is
me by go to sourish it's been an honor
don't stop it ain't over t series is
hundred connivance fights I'm not saving
enough moment gameplay hey hey
imagine if you couldn't watch the videos
you love imagine if you couldn't watch
the videos you love because the platform
they were on they monetize them and all
the creators because we came unmotivated
and stopped making the content they were
previously paid for
yeah
yeah too animated who are your favorite
enemies that's great
huge hasn't been getting cocky because
he's taller than Jack and Mark let's
remind him of that one time he was I was
slouching okay there's a difference when
you sit like this and sit like this
that's all I got thank you guys for
watching this episode no way YouTube's
favorite show hope you guys enjoyed
smash like if you did remember to buy
the headphones the hat the the shirt the
G fuel the chair checkup the game and
that's it that's it that's all you got
to do that's all I'm asking for what
else
Jesus I'm just a I'm just a struggling
youtuber please you want pyramids we got
them
oh you're into castles huh we got you
covered baby you want some bets easy
we got it all this game is still
relevant goddammit
[Music]